pourquoi c'est pas que hugo lloris a
mais quand on est quand on est connu
quand on fait la fête pourquoi quand on
part en boîte pour comprend pas un
chauffeur ou à ou pire à taxi pour
rentrer à bon pote qui pourra les clés
surtout aussi ainsi après bon ça arrive
avec manny faut bien sûr pas le faire
c'est très dangereux savent c'est dans
cette idée dangereuse et perdons et moi
dans ces moments là je pense à toutes
les familles qui elles ont vécu des
drames
là il s'est rien passé d'alors on me dit
qu'il avait commandé un changement mais
que le jugement n'est jamais venu il dit
que nick a évidemment comme il était
ivre du coup il a pris sa voiture mais
ils avaient quand même commander un taxi
se poser est ce que ça vous choque
mais s'il a fait ce qu'il a fait bien
sûr d'accord je veux dire aujourd'hui on
veut pas rigoler tellement chaque année
on peut être que choqué après l'image
est ternie quoi c'est pas du tout non
c'est le français qui cartonne le plus
marketing et les devants antoine
griezmann de vente qui a même bape et
c'est celui qui a la meilleure image au
niveau des pulls oui et là je pense que
malheureusement un fait comme ça
s'allume un cerf et le retour de bâton
intérêt là ça malheureusement
effectivement c'est choquant maintenant
il faut dire quelque chose toutes les
célébrités on dit quoi et on vous savez
vous êtes bien placé pour savoir et tout
le monde ici quand y'a un bad buzz faut
pas parler faux pas commenter faut pas
s'exprimer parce que ça passe plus vite
etc
c'est ce qui se dit aujourd'hui on est
d'accord là dessus maintenant je trouve
que quand même il a eu le courage de
s'excuser aujourd'hui en public combien
aujourd'hui deux personnalités se sont
fait arrêter juger pour pire que ça et
non on fait profil bas pour pas en pour
pas envenimer le bad buzz alors que lui
a pris un micro en télé l'a dit excusez
moi moi c'est ridicule ce que j'ai fait
c'est pas bien je suis désolé c'est une
vraie célébrité y en a qui ont fait de
cire et jeunesse
mais au niveau des stars c'est britney
mais si ce pas la tête je pars de
l'image
oui moi je dirais que ça reste un homme
avant tout or cet été il a quand même
changé de statut donc enfin
professionnellement parlant il n'avait
pas le droit de faire ça tout les
erreurs sont pardonnables il s'est
excusé auprès des français à eux de
juger ensuite s'ils souhaitent le
pardonner mon la part d'al parce qu'il
n'y a pas eu de drame l'améliorer un
drame
l affaire aurait pris tout une autre une
autre histoire mais c'est le jeu mais
nicolas à part parce qu'il est
formidable mais tous les autres ici
qu'est critique bolloré surtout toi tu
es hall dharma langue française est
l'anti france on rappelle que vous
prêtez qu'un champion du monde café est
pas parce que c'est l'horizon les
courgettes 1 on peut pas entendre des
choses comme ça on va faire un gamin
raison d'un sondage
quand vous allez le moyen de cet homme
je suis la brouille est pour ça qu un
chauffeur ou vous avez un bon ami qui
vous conseilles tu mets ce que vous
dites c'est inaudible
alors c'est pas possible burris avant
vous oui encore parce qu'en pensent les
gens les écus voilà le tennis pas tout
après ça reste quand même un grand
joueur est bien là mais la coupe du
monde c'est une bêtise
et peut-être aussi que grâce à lui
peut-être grâce aux aa lui aussi à des
gens qui vont peut-être se raisonner les
patins je préfère rater cette
communication était excellente faute
avouée à moitié pardonnée
il doit alors dit un truc là maintenant
j'aime et hugo loris avant qu'ils soient
champions du monde alors je m'intéresse
pas football donc j'avais vu ses
qualités humaines et professionnelles
j'adore ce mec ça m'a fait beaucoup de
peine d'apprendre bon qu'il avait qui
s'était rendu responsable de ça
maintenant c'est vrai qu'il a présenté
ses excuses tant que moi pour moi
l'affairé close espère qu on en restera
là